Is there something,
this is the main question,
is there something,
is there a set of ideas
that Western civilization is
predicated on that are more
than just bloody opinion?
That's the question.
Because if there isn't,
well then what do you,
what do you do about that?
It's arbitrary.
You're just holding it
for no reason whatsoever.
It could be a different system.
There's no reason to stick with it.
All of those things,
like it takes the,
it takes the core out of it.
When that was niches claim,
right?
He said you take the core metaphysical
presupposition out from underneath
Western civilization or any civilization
for that matter and the whole thing
loosens shakings shakes and
crumbles while for nature,
the metaphysical presupposition was God.
Well,
and then the question of course,
well what even does that mean?
And it on one hand it means,
I suppose adherence to a
dogmatic set of beliefs,
but then you might ask yourself,
well,
is there something else that it means?
It means at least the hypothesis
of some transcendent value.
It means at least that.
Yeah.
Oh,
so you know,
Nietzsche announced the death of God.
And so one of the consequences of that
dusty Husky was working on exactly the
same set of ideas and in crime
and punishment in particular,
which is a book could
gets a necessary book.
That's the thing is there's a number
of books that were written in the last
hundred and 20 years that you really
have to read and crime and punishment is
one of them.
And I think the Gulag archipelago is
another and probably beyond good and evil
is another.
But you know,
Dostoyevsky and Nichi
we're writing in parallel.
It's remarkable how much their,
their lives intertwined.
And Nisha knew more about Dostoyevsky
then that is generally don't,
there's been some recent
scholarship indicating that,
but in Dostoyevsky's crime and punishment,
he has a,
his main character,
a risk call Nikolov decides that he's
going to commit a murder and he has very
good justification for the murder.
And Dusty Yefsky is very good at this.
He,
he puts his characters into very,
very difficult moral situations and gives
them full justification for pursuing
the,
uh,
pursuing the pathway
that they're pursuing.
And so risk golden cove,
he's broke and starving.
He wants to go to law school.
His sister's about to
prostitute herself rough,
roughly speaking,
by marrying a guy that hates her,
that she hates and that,
and he has contempt for her,
at least acts in that manner.
He's trying to rescue his mother as well,
who's also in dire financial straits.
He,
he,
he goes to a pawnbroker to pawn his
meager position so that he can continue to
scrape by.
And she has this nice,
I believe it's her niece
that's not very bright,
who she basically treats as an,
as a slave and his horrible too.
And,
and so the carrot that the pawnbroker has
this money risk Niqab is in dire need.
He thinks,
look,
I'll just kill her
because why the hell not?
I'll take her money.
She's not doing any good with it.
Anyways.
I'll free your niece who's
just working as a slave.
She's got all these other people
tangled up in her pawnbroker schemes.
All that'll happen is the
world will be a better place.
And the only thing that's holding me
back is conventional moral cowardice.
And you know,
Dostoyevsky has his character in
crime and punishment go through days,
hours,
hours and days and weeks of intense
imagination about this rationalization,
about this,
trying to justify himself,
placing a metal outside,
placing him self outside the law so that
he can perpetrate this act and telling
him self with all the best nihilistic
arguments that the only possible thing
that could be holding them back is an
an arbitrary sense of indoctrinated
morality.
And so dusty Esky explores that he does
commit the murder and then of course all
hell breaks loose because things don't
necessarily turn out the way that you
want.
He gets away with it.
However,
while he gets away with it technically
because no one knows he did it,
but he doesn't get away with it in
relationship to his own conscience.
And so that the rest of
the book explores that.
Well Dostoyevsky I believe it
was in crime and punishment.
Although he makes the same
point in many of his books.
He makes a very fundamental point,
and this is the kind of point that
that I think that people who haven't
investigated these matters
down this particularly lid,
particular literary and
philosophical pathway,
never grappled with dusty Esky said
straightforwardly if there's no god.
So if there is no higher value,
let's say if there's
no transcendent value,
then you can do whatever you want.
And that's the question
that he's investigating.
And you see,
this is why I have such frustration
say with people like Sam Harris,
the sort of radical atheists,
because they seem to think that
once human beings abandoned their,
their grounding in the transcendent,
that the,
the plausible way forward is with
a kind of purest rationality that
automatically attributes to
other people equivalent value.
It's like I just don't understand that
they believe that that's the rational
pathway.
What the hell is irrational about me
getting exactly what I want from every one
of you whenever I want it
at every possible second.
Why is that a irrational and how
possibly is that more irrational than us
cooperating so we can both
have a good time of it?
I don't understand that.
I mean it's as if the psychopathic
tendency is irrational.
There's nothing irrational about it.
It's pure naked self interest.
How is that irrational?
I don't understand that.
Where,
where's the pathway from rationality to,
to an egalitarian virtue and why the
hell not every man for himself and the
devil take the hindmost.
It's a perfectly coherent philosophy and
is actually one that you can institute
in the world with a fair bit of
material success if you want to do it.
So I don't see,
to me,
I think that that the universe that people
like Dorkins and Harris inhabit is so
intensely conditioned by mythological
presuppositions that they take for granted
the they ethic that emerges out
of that as if it's just a given,
a rational given.
And this of course precisely not niches,
observation as well as dusty
huskies are snitches observation.
You don't get it.
The ethic that you think is normative is
a consequence of its of its rate of its
nesting inside this
tremendously lengthy history,
much of which was expressed
in mythological formulation.
You wipe that out.
You don't get to keep all
the presuppositions and
just assume that they're
rationally axiomatic there.
The rational,
to make a rational argument,
you have to start with
an initial proposition.
While the proposition that underlies
western culture is that there's a
transcendent morality.
Now,
you could say that's a
transcendent morality
instantiated in the finger of God.
That's fine.
You could even call that a personification
of the morality if you want to,
if you don't want to move
into a metaphysical space.
I'm not arguing for the existence of God.
I'm arguing that the ethic that drives
our culture is predicated on the idea of
God and that you can't just take that
idea away and expect the thing to remain
intact midair without
any foundational support.
Now,
you don't have to buy that,
but if you're interested in the idea,
then you can read Nicha because
that's what he was trying to sort out.